the jurogan experience what we have to
realize is that we're americans you know
we're deeply selfish monsters that have
been bred to destroy all life on earth
we can't we have to not lose sight of
that message
we're here to [ __ ] things up for
everyone else
not each other
and that's what we had in the 80s and
the 90s we had a commitment to apathy
while our leaders ran around pillaging
the earth and we made great movies and
great art and it was fine yes people got
killed but people always get killed but
now we're at war with each other where
we we should just be enjoying the spoils
of the end of the empire truly
you should be enjoying people so many
people got killed murdered tortured
maimed for us to have all the nice
things we have do you know how insane it
is to not enjoy it you know how crazy it
is to not enjoy a mcmansion a flat
screen tv a mcflurry you're not going to
pick you know what blood is in the
street for those things and people act
like they don't even matter and they're
fighting about all this [ __ ] it's
crazy
anyway that's the truth that's the real
truth nobody wants to hear it but that
is the truth we have a lot of these
things are nice but some of them are
ill-gotten gains fine you know not
everybody picking tomatoes is happy
about it but have you ever had a good
like a nice jersey thick beef steak
tomato it's good imagine having one and
then fighting with someone about
something it's
stupid
if there's a hell world going and if
there's not we get reincarnated when
we're uh beetles or something but just
enjoy it and nobody wants to enjoy it
and that's what makes me upset
is that we used to have a country built
on enjoyment built on fat stupid people
enjoying the work of a small group of
demons and now we can't even enjoy it
can't even have fun
that would be the only way to get us out
of this that's right if we ever realized
that the problems that we have with
issues are far smaller
than the problems where we or the issues
that we agree on like everybody agrees
we have to have less crime everybody
agrees
that we have to have more education
everybody agrees that we have to have
safer street streets and safer cities
everybody agrees that that's right and
the things that we disagree on
well people disagree on like how to make
those things a reality though how do you
have less crime is it by letting well
it's also people out of jail being
divided helps
it helps people who want to just
continually
operate
in the system as it's constructed
and whether that is
the system of perpetual war or the
system of
the the banking sector the dominance of
the financial sector or the system is
tech companies set up to have this these
political relationships how they're
presently constituted people who are
thriving in this system and using it to
their ends do not want it changed and
people hating each other helps them
it definitely does
do you think that that's just human
nature and you're just doing it while
this is happening or do you think it's
orchestrated this is the question right
is the dissent and is is some of it we
know it's manipulated by other countries
yes we know that china does it we know
that they have these
these huge russian organizations that
that yeah in their troll farms yeah you
know we know that that's going on the
idea that we wouldn't do that to
ourselves
if we were trying to
get people riled up about it to an
extent it's probably a an inherent flaw
in democracy but i'm glad i lived in one
and i'm glad i lived in the time i did
but i do think you know a democracy kind
of descends probably into an oligarchy
eventually the vast majority of the
citizens go i don't want the
responsibility of citizenship so a few
really highly motivated psychopaths go
we'll handle it we'll take it from here
and then those people are fighting over
their own interests
constantly
do you think it should be illegal
to
pretend to represent a human being
when you're a corporation
that is promoting your own needs
so do you think that like a corporation
that hires
whether it's a foreign corporation let's
say it's a form one so it's not
connected to us that that hires a
company to
propagandize about uh a specific
political issue that's gonna be a hot
button target and they do it as a bunch
of people that attack people yes and go
after people with dissenting opinions
and and quote tweet them and attack them
and you find out it's not even a real
person right that should be illegal that
seems to me like if we're allowing that
in this country oh yeah but we will
continue to allow anyone with enough
money right but don't you think that
that thing right there just that that's
insidious pretending you're a person for
a specific propaganda and and having it
like a thousand accounts and you're
running it through computers and you've
got people responding to things you got
people that are just retweeting things
and posting things and it's all just
it's saying that the congress the people
the congress members who
went and started trading stocks based on
the knowledge of how bad coronavirus was
still have jobs right all of this is
kind of insane we're just at peak
insanity here
and there's you know i mean are we at
the peak i don't know if we're at the
peak but it's it's we're close to it
like i i do believe with the way things
are going
and you're looking at
uh
some really crazy trends and i don't
know when they come to a conclusion and
if they do
uh without something you know a war or
some violent or whatever but like it is
just you know we're living in a time now
where we all know everything's [ __ ]
but we're mostly powerless to change it
and that's when society start to decay
past a point
and everybody just kind of sits back and
watches it like a show
and it just descends into eventually
something that becomes more and more
unmanageable
and then either a strong man dictator
type comes in or there's some massive
war that resets things or there's some
natural disaster but it feels like we're
kind of at that point you know that's
why i'm glad we lived in the era that we
lived and that's we really should just
be happy
we should be really up we should go
it's it's nice that we got the run we
did because it's not getting better
i mean here's what's interesting or
maybe it will and god bless when i was a
kid i remember reading about like the
fall of the roman empire and the fall of
the greek empire and then i was thinking
about america yeah and i was like is
this thing gonna go away someday right
right is that possible is it possible
that this is just one i mean we want to
think it's [ __ ] permanent but i bet
the people of rome felt the same way of
course
this this is how it is this is how i
live every day this is not going to
change right and russians know they know
they know
there's
nothing will ever be funnier
america will come apart in one of the
funniest ways
all of these people these grifters
everybody circling the wagons the
caitlyn jenner is the donald trump it'll
be funny until you'll let you'll die
laughing literally you'll die let you'll
die but you will be laughing um it will
be the most absurd and insane thing it
will be out of a
[ __ ]
dystopian horror movie
and no it'll never be it won't be
funnier than
than america because we're a crazy
country
with full of crazy people and
everybody's just trying to suck the last
few dollars out of this bloated pig
corpus
corpse of an empire
before the end
and i'm no different watch my special
and subscribe to my pot what am i going
to [ __ ] sit here what am i going to
go preach on a [ __ ] mountain we got
to make a little money here but make no
mistake
i mean if i'm wrong and i'd love to be
wrong but if your attitude or your idea
is that the population's going to get
smarter
healthier and more adept at problem
solving you're on [ __ ] crack
oh
yeah
yeah probably you're probably right
yeah
but what happens next like do you think
that we ever descend into some sort of
like
ccp controlled world
like that kind of totalitarian
government do you think it's possible
that through technology and just through
people just being just falling apart
getting losing their [ __ ] minds
thinking it's the right thing to do i
think what happens next is we'll just
have you know these uh giant oscillating
swings between right and left and then i
think you know eventually you'll get to
a point where large areas in the country
are unlivable for a myriad of reasons
perhaps crime or homelessness climate
whatever um very
you know well-off or well-connected
people will have these kind of enclaves
that are this is already happening and
then there'll be you know a fight to be
in one of those two groups and then
eventually a dictator a strong miss
somewhere down the line some man or
woman will come in and go this system's
[ __ ]
i am going to run things
and they will run
things
in in a way and it will probably won't
be for the best but like the system will
collapse but i don't know if we'll see
it
but it will collapse
there's no way it doesn't
it will collapse to a degree and someone
will come in and go yeah these elections
are all fake and it doesn't matter
anyway why do you [ __ ] need to vote
here's a coupon for chicken sandwich and
people go i like chicken and then you
know people just go [ __ ] it they don't
care and then you go they'll be netflix
and they'll be dominoes and you'll sit
in your house and they'll say you can't
drive today because of the climate and
people go yeah it's tuesday can't get my
car because of climate and you'll sit
there and they'll give you they'll feed
you poison and you'll watch tv uh and a
few people will riot but very few
because most people will be pacified by
the goodies which they'll still probably
have and you know the leader will come
on and tell like well they'll be like
hello everyone and you're like
and it'll be a celebrity it'll be
someone you know it'll be someone you're
very familiar with and they'll say a
couple of things and be like it's not
that bad is it they go nah it's not that
bad and they'll feed you the propaganda
and you won't remember when you were
free and you won't remember and most
people will be fine with that but me and
you will be dead
and it won't matter
you know and will have experienced the
best of it well remember when you could
get in a car without a tracking device
or remember when you didn't have a
[ __ ] tracking device attached to you
at all times well remember when you
could say what the [ __ ] you want
alienate people piss them off and no one
really cared and it didn't matter
because you could wake up the next day
and say sorry i was drunk and it wasn't
on [ __ ] twitter people didn't have a
record of what you did and what you said
and where you were and who you [ __ ]
and everything else we will remember
true freedom we're one of the last
groups of people to actually be free and
we should all thank god for that because
the hellscape that's about to be created
is going to be so bad they won't even
know how bad it is it won't even feel
like they're in prison because those
offices we talked about people they get
to like them oh there's creamer today
french vanilla it's your favorite
it's coming
it's coming and it's gonna be so bad it
won't even feel bad but we'll be like
[ __ ]
remember when you could do all those
things you can't do anymore but you know
and there'll be a few people that
remember it and then they'll take all
those books about that [ __ ] and burn the
[ __ ] out of them they'll go well those
aren't good racism homophobia burn burn
burn and people will forget
when you could were free and they would
just kind of create a society based on
goodies
little goodies little rewards and the
addiction to celebrity where our leaders
will all be celebrities who will tell
you on closed circuit television how
good things are going and you'll go good
thanks
which was gonna happen
that was one of the best rants i've ever
heard in my life yeah that's fantastic
i hope you're wrong i hope i'm wrong or
if i'm right
i just hope that i'm dead or i get to be
one of the people who's keeping everyone
else in the cage